was wir im Moment erleben in Deutschland
ist doch ein hochgradiger politischer
Skandal
Minister Habeck hat in seinem Hause
zusammen mit Ministerin Lemke den
Weiterbetrieb der Atomkraftwerke prüfen
lassen das Ergebnis wurde vorweggenommen
ich finde das das ist doch das ist doch
da muss doch sofort Konsequenzen gezogen
werden
Minister für einen Sündenfall dieser
Bundesregierung der ist nicht länger
tragbar er hat gelogen er und Frau Lemke
haben gelogen
wenn es geprüft wird und es wird gar
nicht ernsthaft geprüft sondern es steht
hinten auf der Seite schon ach der
Beschluss wir steigen auch die Grünen
haben ja tausende von Posten besetzt in
den Ämtern hat mit Trittin angefangen
und auch da habe ich halt überall seine
grünen Leute reingetan das fies sogar
die letzten ökonomisch denkenden von
Vernunft geprägten Beamten im
Wirtschaftsministerium gegen Habeck
votiert haben aber das wurde unter